let's play a game
let's say he wins this election somehow
there's a you know less than 20 15
chance yeah let's say he loses yeah
you know what what's the famous line um
uh losers don't get to write the history
quote
help me out here with quote winners
write history there's gonna be a
different narrative if trump wins
re-election wins eight years there's a
story behind it
you know comes in and shakes the system
up and
rocks things he's there for eight years
gets re-elected i mean he can write that
story
he does not get re-elected what do what
is his
tombstone his obituary sound like if he
only wins four years
versus eight years what does that sound
like to you
i think i think his uh
and this is a shame because of what he
did
uh in the beginning of his term because
of some of the funding that went into
african-american colleges uh
because of opportunity zones and other
efforts that were made because
of him tearing back regulations because
he made it
easier to do business in america
[Music]
and was kind of the architect
of bringing the unemployment rate down
to a 50-year low
a lot of that was federal reserve policy
a lot of it was but it was also making
it easier to do business in america
which at last
check it should be easy it's america
there should have never been all that
red tape in the in the obama years
period end
but i'm not so sure that history is
going to give him that
credit because of where the economy is
headed now
and because the coronavirus has hit
uh the minority working population
so so hard so it's going to remain to be
seen if we're entering
a dark chapter in u.s history then
you could look to spiteful historians
especially
spiteful historians who feel like
they've been marginalized
in a trump world think about your
typical political pundit
who's basically been you know in
hibernation for the last four years
inside the beltway
he hasn't he hasn't needed people to
tell him
what to think nor has he needed advisers
to tell him what to say
he thinks it he tweets it i mean there's
really no
there's no stopping him in between um
but it it it is possible that he not
gets the credit that he deserves
for some of the things that he did
accomplish for the us economy
what do you think it sounds like if he
only wins four years versus eight years
listen
let's just face it this is one of the
most competitive if not the most
competitive person we've had as a
president in the history of america yeah
it's extremely competitive at least the
last fifty years that we know about all
the other stuff i don't disagree okay
he's extremely competitive but
i don't mind having a guy like that on
my side i just don't i don't mind having
a guy like that on my side
um he's gonna hate it he will be
miserable
he will hate life too personal like that
it'll be
very very hard for him publicly he'll
act fine deep down inside the guy cannot
stand
losing he hates losing when michael lost
you
felt the pain you know he hated it and
you loved him for it because you loved
how much it mattered to him that he lost
that's where he's at
he's going to hate losing and i love
that i love the fact that it matters so
much to a guy who's going to hate losing
is he going to be the kind of a guy
that's going to come out and say well
you know we've
lost you know we lost and they won fair
and square i
i'm going to say no he's not going to do
that he's going to come out he's going
to put a comment and say well you know
it is what it is now what are they going
to write about him meaning like that's
what
i'm going to i'm going to say this to
you if you give me a second so yes sir
we've had
we've had uh uh three uh one-term
presidents in the last
50 years 40 years we had what ford
carter
senior project i was hoover yeah senior
of course when against
but you know first of all ford
anomaly you know put him on a completely
different side
because of what hap how he became a
president he didn't even win re-election
for
whatever you know ford is ford so then
you have
a uh carter who won the worst presidents
we've had nicest guy
nice guys sweetheart a horrible
president
uh we had just i'm in america because of
carter just so you know that there's no
carter i'm still in iran i'm here in
america because of carter i was about to
say
so so bring carter back in the
discussion continue and then you have uh
bush senior which uh honestly bush
senior to me was more of a c.o.o
he was never ceo there's a difference
between a ceo and he's never number one
no he's not a number one he's a guy
behind closed doors that's a great
project manager give him a project he
will lead it he'll get it done
that was him he was never the guy that's
going to come out and inspire people
it's just
you never saw him like that and ross
showed up from texas he will be
trump will be the uh will be loved
admired adored by a lot of people on his
side
now is he going away that's the question
the question isn't really legacy because
legacy's gonna have both sides there's
gonna be sides that's gonna comedians
are gonna
love trashing them well no no no no no
it's going to go to hold down you think
it's going to get even
it's going to go to a whole different
way i can't wait for snl his reaction
what they're going to
it's going to go to a whole different
level if he loses comedians are going to
rock the house saying i told you so this
guy they're going to crush the tv
the don lemons of the world the cuomo's
of the world the coopers they're going
to be loving life the next four years
however
he's 74. in four years he'll be biden's
age
if there's anybody that's the kind of
person that's going to prepare the next
four years to make a comeback and come
and ruin these guys lives if there's one
guy that would do something like that
it's trump can he run again in four
years that works yes he can
okay yes oh he will okay yeah he can
he'll be running against
it's happened before so you're answering
my question you're actually answering my
question
jimmy carter
rank rank presidents
living living presidents who have
brought more to their country
current living presidents that have
brought meaning what like done
good done good for their country in
their lifetimes living presidents
clinton that have done good meaning they
did a good time when they were four
years they didn't afford the economy
after they left office including their
time after office oh carter's uh
carter's a
non-profit charity guy involved active
yeah he just wasn't a good president
foreign relations terrible president
continuing to to work
outside of america on america's best
betty ford is the same if you put the
ford family they did as well there's a
lot yes sure
but but carter's legacy is pretty
incredible
not as a president for for how bad his
presidency is
as a human being and okay uh w george w
he disappeared and has been what
gracious even though he was he never
undermined obama
obama has done his best friend now he
never undermined obama even obama every
day said i got a bad administration he
trashed bush but
bush never trashed obama dignified big
time big time dignified
i mean i got his picture there in my
office because i like the way he handled
himself but what he did is he
disappeared he didn't want the limelight
he gave it to obama right
sure and and and obamacare and his his
legacy now is there for
pristine sure so i wouldn't say pristine
he
went into the iraq he caused he doesn't
there were a lot of things there were
there's still people that don't like
personality is is i understand
well-regarded but some of his policies
right but i'm not talking about what he
did as president i'm talking about
legacy
yeah four years from now let's say trump
does not run what does his legacy look
like
well that's essentially that's what i
was to who to the country
as a whole i don't see it that way i
think i think
forever there is a playbook for future
trumps
forever everybody who sees themselves as
a trump who's not a career politician
who wants to one day run for office
whether they're a democrat or republican
trump officially gave the playbook oprah
rock trump officially gave him the
playbook trump gave him the playbook to
say
trump secretly is many people's hero but
they cannot say publicly
listen many people voted for trump you
know how you ask people and say who'd
you vote for i'm not going to say you
voted for trump
who the hell would say i'm not going to
say if you voted for biden you you like
for example
you know remember wait a minute remember
megyn kelly remember megyn kelly
megan kelly years ago she tried to play
the card because she wanted to be oprah
i don't know if you guys remember she
wanted to get like an oprah contract she
couldn't get that so megan kelly in 2016
she's got
she's passed a bill o'reilly people are
watching making kelly more than watching
bill o'reilly
everybody's like dude i'm tuning in to
making kelly and then all of a sudden
megan kelly started playing
the card of i'm not really this
i'm not really that and she's got the
contract and then she got the contract
and she trashed fox where's megan kelly
today
where's mick if megan kelly would have
stood ground and said look i have
problems with fox i don't like to stick
but i'm gonna do this and i'm gonna
stick to my positions megyn kelly would
have ruled the world today i agree but
what happened
there is this community she went
hollywood there is this community that
is
afraid of uh where they're gonna be
secretly
millions of people admire trump and a
lot of people are gonna use this guy's
playbook
dude you gotta realize i mean you know
how hard it is to give
not give credit to a guy that his entire
career
he played business he did everything he
ever wanted
and then at the end of the day he says
you know what i'm going to go freaking
run for office
out of 16 people the only person that
said this guy's going to win it all was
who was the only crazy psycho
you know woman that said oh this guy's
going to win it and called
bill says if it ends today trump's when
he's like
what are you out of your mind obama made
fun of him
everybody robert downey i'm not robert
downey jr george clooney everybody joked
about this guy
and he won against hillary clinton who
was supposed to be madame secretary
queen of
the world he beat hillary clinton so
there is a part that legacy wise this
guy
changed the game love him or hate him he
changed the game look
i don't have to like lebron to know he
changed the game i don't have to like
somebody to say a person change the game
trump absolutely changed the game win or
lose but i'm gonna tell you listen
adam there are certain people when they
make millions they disappear
there are certain people in the game of
basketball they win one championship
they disappear
there are certain people they get a nice
corporate job they disappear there's
certain people that you used to lose to
they get this much of a victory they
disappear this is not that guy
no just so you know this this is not
that guy and not only is he not gonna
disappear
so people say well he's gonna disappear
when he dies absolutely not even when he
dies whatever he dies
yeah the trump spirit is going to be in
so many younger
if he loses i'm going to tell you what's
going to happen if he loses say he loses
say he loses brother
danielle if this guy loses
you officially have a group of
tens of thousands not millions because
it's not true believers
tens of thousands of true believers that
are not going to forget this
are not gonna forget this
and we're gonna see what they're gonna
be doing the next two four six eight ten
twenty years so he parlays this into
i mean the the running theory the
conventional wisdom is that he parlays
this into
his own network that he unseats fox
fox news he could easily do that he
becomes the next rupert murdoch he could
easily do that but i don't know i don't
i i don't know if he is going to be
satisfied with just that because
you know when you've reached a
mountaintop of a certain business you're
just kind of like annoyed by it
and you go and you start negotiating
with other dignitaries and presidents
and prime ministers
you really want to go back to
negotiating with other presidents of
ceos of companies you're bored you're
like dude i played this game already who
the hell wants to go win basketball at
ymca when you're playing at college
level
when you're in the nba who wants to go
play against college level and be collar
so where where can he go
where where where can he go to be bigger
here's where he can go phenomenal
question here's where he can go
where he can go is what republicans
haven't been doing
i'm in chicago at the ritz carlton a few
years ago five
before uh or oba before uh trump so put
it 14 15. i'm at the ritz
and there's two thousand
african-american men and women
in their 18 19 20 21 sharp
all look ridiculous like i'm talking
beautiful three-piece suit
the ladies wearing nice dresses like the
ones you put together
everybody's looking money right and i'm
like what are you guys doing here
with the future democratic lawyers
of the african-american community so
what's this all about he says well we're
a
private organization we come together
who's your hero barack obama what do you
guys want to be
we're all running for one day maybe
we'll be president and let me tell you
it was so flipping impressive i'm like
dang this is impressive so he's breeding
the next obama it's good for you
if trump really loves america if he
really loves america
okay which but people who believe in him
believe that this guy really loves
america
and the foundation america was founded
on he wants to protect that if he does
the next thing he's got to do is figure
out more the university route the more
the education route the more the rally
and the next
troops rod duplicating himself right
it's not through corporation it's about
i'm gonna bring two three four thousand
young cats
and i'm gonna get this mindset in their
brain over and over
and over and over and over and over
again
for this spirit to last for the next 50
600 years you're saying that's the
direction that he should go i don't
think the media
i think the media is going to be a small
play for him listen i'm not saying he
can't do it i think he could do it
but i think he's got you know two kids
that could one day run for office
he's got a son-in-law that could run for
office he's got
a son that's 14 years old that's one
they're going to be the center of
whatever but
he can run for office he could run for
office after he plays his professional
basketball
kids listen what happened to kennedy
legacy beyond you're saying
no these guys are not going to go away
they're not going to go away well you
know i mean the hoover institute it's
it's stanford very conservative uh
organization
has been speaking out vociferously
saying that the liberal university
system in america
is killing uh free speech and the first
amendment
and you know what patrick i think that
there is an appetite
to bring balance back into higher
education in america such that it's not
such
a one leaning way of thinking and
parents you know i've got kids who who
will be going to university in a few
years
i completely applaud that i have why pay
all this money intuition to send your
child off to be brainwashed in one way
i mean theoretically higher learning
should teach them how to think for
themselves
and not be brainwashed so if something
like that i think has
tremendous appetite in the united states
i agree so i'm thinking it's more
university than i'm thinking it's about
but what you're describing is a little
bit more dignified than what i would
expect from trump so
good for him if he's going to raise the
bar for himself
to start influencing the next generation
of conservative thinkers in america
we need that no i i you you won't give
me your give me he's not a conservative
thinker that's not his brand
he he will he will look listen
uh capitalism marxism right marxism is
behind whose name
a person's names karl marx marxism trump
is not about i'm a conservative
republican trump would much
rather have a trump circumstance yeah
trumpism he is
about that right so he's not it has to
be branded around
it's populism isn't it isn't it like
bravado
i don't understand this guy who he is i
understand who trump is i've been in
business with people like trump and you
don't mind having a guy like that on
your camp
you don't mind having a guy like that on
your account oh if you're going doing
business yeah hell no
you don't mind having to sign me up not
only business you would have loved the
democratic trump let me tell you
democrats would have loved a trump
that's a democrat give me
give me a democrat who that's true who
would be you guys are very quick to jump
to conclusion if that guy was wearing
your color jersey you
love him he's your guy give me wait
wait wait wait wait let me shoot me the
big timeout right here because i
i support the person so what did i get
for supporting
the person when i was when i when i
lived in new york city
what did i get for supporting the person
because here comes hillary clinton
running for the senate in the state of
new york and i'm like
i don't get that not her state i don't
understand i i don't understand
i was raised so there i go i go register
i go register to vote change my driver's
license in the city of new york
i vote i go completely knowing
completely i'm wasting my vote
voting for this guy rick lazio who
nobody's heard of anymore
in new york or in new york so i you know
i've been living in new york for seven
years
the one thing new yorkers kept saying is
danielle don't get rid of your texas
driver's license don't ever
ever get a new york driver's license
don't ever vote
in the state of new york you will get
jury duty so fast your head spins within
two weeks
what do i get jury duty but i didn't
know who rick lazio was but i did know
that hillary clinton had no business
being in the state of new york
it wasn't her state so in order to vote
against her i went out and did my civic
duty
and registered as a republican in the
state of new york and went and voted for
this rick
person just to make my statement to
hillary
so don't don't ever pigeonhole me you
never know pitching all you with what
with which part if you just said if
trump said to him
you're saying to him no i i don't put
you as a no i don't think he was going
to know
where you are i'm not going at you at
all no i know you're he wasn't going
out of
it's not about whether he would have
made a better democrat or republican all
i'm saying is
if democrats had a trump they would
adore him who's the democratic trump
let's say let's say biden wins cool
he doesn't want to run for reelection
but democrats say you know what
cuomo who are you thinking as a democrat
i'm asking you
are you asking yeah i'm asking you who's
the democratic trump well you're not
you're not going to have many democratic
trumps
bloomberg is not a democratic trump
couldn't cuomo is not a democratic trump
because he hasn't
the only person that could be a
democratic trump the only person
and he's not as much of a true believer
as trump is the only person that could
is a cuban
the only person mark cuban he could
cuban could be a democratic trump huh
what about like saying yeah how
diplomatic is the rock
hey brother let me tell you no no no no
he's very diplomatic when it comes to
politics diplomatic
how diplomatic is cuban he's pretty
brash he's not exactly
what i'm trying to say and he's a
billionaire and he's a spoiler and he's
a tv guy and he's a shark tanker
the closest yeah not just a big
personality a person that's willing to
go to war
and likes the heat okay but he likes the
heat but go back to your point go back
to your point because it's really
important that we
shape not that we shape the thinking but
that we
teach that we teach college age kids
how to think for themselves so i don't
care i don't care what trump is
is if it's trumpism that he's selling or
conservatism
that doesn't matter what we need in our
university system is
to get to get away from and to escape
free of
unilateral thinking it can't just be
left left left liberal
or liberal in all of our universities
and colleges because it's just a
gigantic waste of money
let me tell you why i respect trump i
know this is the angle we were going to
go
here we go here's our respect trump we
asked about the obituary and
legacy what have you it's pretty clear
that
that biden has a very very very likely
path to 270 right
um think about who biden was running
against biden was running against trump
periods full stop who was trump running
against three major things
while he was running against biden in
the dnc
there's one he's running against covid
a freaking pandemic and the third thing
is he's running against the media
so trump is going against three very
powerful entities
and the pollsters pollsters you might
say
um and almost pulled it off
and and according to him did pull it off
so
trump's a fighter he's brash no doubt uh
there's high likelihood he'll be back in
just because i can see him getting super
salty and just getting
pumped up and getting riled up and like
what he's saying
in the last debate i ran because of you
joe biden so he's gonna look at what joe
biden potentially does over the next
four years and
and regroup uh if not we'll see where
the republican party is
let me tell you he's just going to have
to lay off the big machines he will not
he will let me tell you what's going to
happen
what obama did you know what obama did
tell me
the fact that obama didn't stop
trashing trump after trump got elected
and do what bush did to him
trump is going to do to obama a million
times
more trump to obama biden both of them
he's gonna go at their throats non-stop
for four years
it's gonna be at levels you've never
seen before but obama can just say one
thing that trump will
obama be like i was here for eight buddy
you were here for four
have a nice day you don't think trump's
gonna like get so
heated just hearing that yeah do you i'm
double as good as you buddy you're not
thinking so he's gonna come back talker
who's a better smackdocker
i think they're both good if you want to
go down and dirty trump if you want to
go high and classy and well-worded obama
okay okay what i'm saying what happens
when he's being offered a million
dollars every time he stands in front of
a podium
what about it he takes it but what's
your what's your point though you mean
you don't get it
you don't think he'll you don't think
there's any way that he'll take the
former president dignified no hell no
no no because you're not paying him a
million bucks to give that talk
the key word there was dignified
danielle you understand what i'm saying
you're not you're not giving a million
dollars to give that speech
if you want that speech you give it to
somebody else not to him you're giving
them the million dollars to come up and
talk trash
you're basically bringing them to the
wwe you're giving them the money for
that but
it's about to be gangbusters and
he loses brother there is certain people
shouldn't lose
there are certain opponents you don't
want them to lose publicly
you just don't who else there's some
people you
you do not want a a tiger an mj you
don't want certain competitors to lose
what do you mean you don't want them to
lose what does that mean
if you're their opponent you don't want
to beat them and i'll tell you what
there's a lot of there's 70 plus million
people that would love to see him lose
not to deal with that not the voters not
the voters
the opponents the opponents not the
voters i still think that they want him
to lose
i don't disagree with you but i don't
disagree here's what i don't think
biden's going to do
i don't think biden is going to go at
trump's throat
i don't think i don't think biden has it
in his dna
i think kamala will oh yeah i don't
think biden will i don't think biden
will i think come on
biden will have an opportunity to
potentially at some point
pardon trump pardon trump
uh i think that's a where are you going
with that danielle yeah exactly so well
there are hundreds of thousands of
dollars of debts that become due that
are
presumably in a holding pattern as long
as he's still president i mean his his
taxes are still under audit
no no i'm not talking about his tax
she's not talking taxes she's talking
about other things but listen
to to say pardon you have to have things
to pardon you know it's
that's a technical question you're
asking when you're gonna stop beating
your wife you know type of a thing
that's automatically putting the guy as
beating his wife so i get what you did
right there but
all i'm saying to you is this guy is not
a guy you want to lose
and we're all going to see how he's
going to lose
you